so one point Jon Snow tells Sansa that
any sentence that has a work but in it
makes any words that came before it not
matter I'm paraphrasing here and it's
really not that important to the episode
but I tell people that all the time and
that's why I'm growing my hair out to be
Jon Snow for Halloween
alright ladies and gentlemen winter is
here and it's still hot as hell in LA
now before I go to this review I wanted
to give a quick shout out to today's
sponsor which is nobody this video is
not sponsored I just like trolling
people because people hate product
placement alright so I just got done
watching the episode and I'm pretty
tired right now I'm quite exhausted so
I'm gonna edit this video it's a
tomorrow morning so the videos coming to
you from beyond hello people of July's
17 before going into this review I'll
quickly say that I really did enjoy this
episode because each season plays out
like a specific chapter in the series I
don't mean chapter like a book I don't
want to get this game of Thrones
confusion book thing mixed up I mean
chapter like in television series format
hopefully you still understand one
transit and then this first episode it
is all set up for the way season 7 will
unfold
so nothing incredibly exciting occurred
it's only the first episode it's just a
lot of anticipation for what's to come
you know the true Game of Thrones
fashion a lot build-up okay so the
opening scene of this episode played out
needle Walter for a he's having another
feast with his soldiers he starts to
give a speech explaining why he's having
this feast and at first you really think
you're just watching a flashback because
I'm not saying that I go out ways he's
still alive I was I was sold it was a
flashback on watch then he starts to
recap the events of the red wedding and
right away I was like oh wait a minute
that's Aria in disguise I was absolutely
right sure I called it yeah okay she
called it anyway I loved that scene it
played out like Oh in a wonderful
misleading way and it was a victory for
Aria I thought it's cool that show
starts off with a victory for one of the
Starks I love what she says leave one
wolf alive and the Sheep are never safe
even though she's not fighting alongside
brand
or John directly she's waging her own
war and succeeding whilst representing
as a North baby but as I'm saying this
what it means what does it mean I know
that I'm to yes and to her points that
means that she they should have just
killed all the stars okay I know I would
say why I thought the line was cool and
the next scene we see is the White
Walkers and it's funny seeing the recap
that played before this because I
remember how the first couple seasons
the White Walkers yeah we were all we
knew they were bad but we they weren't
like the central villain but right now
especially from this first episode
they're really building to become the
main central villain and they didn't
really reveal much with the White
Walkers what we saw that the Giants they
killed before they're now white walkers
- which makes sense that's scary because
you know how hard it is to take down a
giant if you ever tried killing
Shaquille O'Neal I haven't bran shows up
to reunite with his brother John snow at
the Nights Watch which of course Jon
Snow is not there nothing really new
with bran other than he's probably going
to be chilling up at Nights Watch and he
has a cool haircut brands really not in
this episode at all I think there's more
screen time dedicated to Samwell Tarly
cleaning up [ __ ] and there is actual
footage of bran in this episode more on
that later we catch up with Jon Snow
who's now the new king of the north he's
leading the people with Sansa by his
side the wildlings are there that a
little badass girl from bear island or
whatever is there and Jon so are these
it's also about what to do with the
people of I think umber and Karstark
there's a lot of names keep up with and
I thought this scene was very engaging
it shows you a lot that is forming in
terms of dynamics
Jon Snow is still learning to be a
leader he's even at a higher position
now well salsa is an aide who has some
really cool badass points but she's also
kind of undermining Jon in front of the
people so we're seeing here that Jon and
salsa will have to learn how to
communicate better with each other
communication is very important there's
a great book called the art of
communication for Jon who doesn't you
could buy it off Amazon and John seems
to have dealt with real pain his entire
life that busted some how you say
bastard in all Game of Thrones up
bust it you'd be having a normal
conversation with though this is John
snow he's a bastard son of Ned stone
John he has sympathy and understanding
and can think long term and what's
really necessary and right so Alfonso
doesn't agree with this decision fully
John so decides to continue in alliance
with umber and Karstark I like what's
happening with Tom so today you know
they had a little exchange of dialogue
with John snow where it does kind of
seem like something has taken on some
attributes of Cersei from the time she
spent with it which is what I think made
Littlefinger smile at one point when she
was interjecting into Jon Snow's speech
and that conversation they're having
afterwards where John is telling Santa
that she can't undermine him in front of
the people
Sansa then comparison to Joffrey which I
feel serves as a reminder of just how
far and how much Sansa has changed and
one way does represent that Thompson
wants to have a voice that she does want
to be able to represent something and
not just be silenced but it also made me
go man remember before Joffrey how non
traumatised Sansa was blond and bred did
something on her man then we catch up
with Cersei who took time out of her day
to have that giant map that Daddy Cersei
showed her to turn into a giant painting
on the ground she knows what the first
most necessary steps are now to do as
Queen she needs a bigger version of the
map I thought this thing was also
interesting because Cersei is the one
that everyone's really talking about you
know the big main human villain of the
show who's going to be the one to kill
her what is she gonna die but when her
and Jamie are going through the map that
giant map they start to argue and Jamie
starts bringing up some really good
points right now they don't have a good
winning chance they're not the most
powerful people anymore so in this
coming war they're kind of the underdogs
or who could win this war and I thought
that was a fascinating establishing
point for the Lannisters themselves and
we also see Jamie and Cersei they're
disagreeing a lot they're having a lot
of tension between them they haven't
talked about Tommen Tommen I don't know
the American way to pronounce it Tommen
dying yet and Cersei continues being the
ruthless [ __ ] she is
by saying common betrayed them when she
killed the love of his life and iron
fist and now that actor is the star of
iron fist that is the worst thing she
could have done already from them
disagreeing it was making me go man you
know I agree with the theories Jaime is
gonna kill her in the end
then when you're on you know when you're
on Greyjoy
urine Greyjoy's of the shirt called here
on graduation arrives and she tells
Jamie their meeting because Jamie was
like you know we needed an alliance
happening Jamie's like there's no way
this would be a good alliance and then
she tells him he's looking at for a
queen it was like who do you not realize
the burn you just landed on Jamie you're
being so mean to Jamie
that's why Jamie's gonna kill you in the
end gosh it is so hard being
romantically involved with your sister
not that I would know but I know plenty
of people who have this is La it's
especially hard when you're sleeping
together and you have three dead
children you know it's just a lot I
don't want to get a get past in order to
make the relationship work I really love
to see when you're on Greyjoy is talking
with Cersei giving her his proposal he
starts to butt heads with Jamie he's
talking about the battle where him and
Jamie were both sad at the same time and
that he was admiring Jamie but it's like
were you really admiring Jamie or just
kind of toy with Jamie what are you
really up to but then he started telling
Cersei that he wants to marry her and he
starts taking jabs at Jamie
he knows that Jamie and Cersei probably
slept together because of the rumors
that were spread it's a great scene
because of the actors dynamics in that
same Iran is looking confident as hell
Jamie just keeps looking back and forth
like what are a little bit sorry
thinking about the oldest issue like it
and Cersei even though she denies his
proposal
you could tell she kind of wipes the
curry yeah Jamie's in killer you know
you're wrong about Jaime and Cersei
right it's gonna be Aria which is face
Kevin Thursday I feel something on the
policies but Aria gets her revenge then
we go to the library where we see
Samwell Tarly has a [ __ ] job literally
it's a [ __ ] job three straight minutes
dedicated to him cleaning up people's
[ __ ] and then serving them soup that
looks like this [ __ ] he was cleaning up
earlier and I actually did like that
touch in a weird way because Sam went
there because he believed he actually
found his purpose is Tru Calling
but his life has become rather mundane
and repetitive like most American adults
working a nine-to-five job Game of
Thrones has become relatable for the
modern-day audience yeah
I really like the same then Sam is
helping and I think I got the name down
subtitles very archmaester Marwan IMDB
looking to someone way better and
they're like dissecting or doing an
autopsy on a body because Game of
Thrones even score and there's no
violence action scene in this episode so
they need to find some way to throw some
of that in there
or yeah maybe there was another Mel
lifestyle and weirdly it's this
character but I don't recall from an
earlier episode that actually gives some
light and a little bit of hope because
he believes the end will not come
because he thinks the whole idea the end
coming has been a part of history of
people fearing that and I kind of is
sure I mean even today you see people
picketing the ends coming you know if
you drive down to like Studio City
called white people petitioning and also
it's a good it's a good moment for Sam
too because while he's bent down on his
luck this whole time he actually
believes Sam has really encountered a
white Walker then we come back to Arya
who's riding her horse looking badass
she encounters some soldiers in the
Riverland and they're singing a
beautiful song they're singing this song
I would learn fingers and there's no
instrument so I started doing this and I
went someone in there sounds like they
could be a professional dissipated
actually get a professional and sure
enough I totally called it it was Ed
Sheeran and then you even asked me which
one her to point out to you that's her
as it'll go up on YouTube in the episode
was done but at one point when Aria says
well I've never heard that song before
he could have practically delivered that
line into the camera when he says it's a
new song and I like to sing too because
Aria on the road and countering soldiers
first thing you'd expect ah she's
probably gonna try to kill them was it
probably bad I think Aria has her right
to be suspicious to me in the game of
Thrones world and at one point she's
even eyeing their swords and the way it
was shot was kind of making me as
beliefs think like oh is she gonna try
to kill these guys and take their swords
but I feel like she chooses not to harm
these peoples after talking with him she
sees that these guys are good people
showing that she's not just some
ruthless killer she hasn't turned into
that she still spares the good and plus
one of them is edge
cheering you can't kill a famous person
you will get caught there we seen the
hound Thoris and then Darian the Darian
I don't know if there's an end after the
DA they had out at this place that's
covered in snow because winter is here
where they find a rotting corpse of man
holding his equally rotted daughter I
mean at first I didn't even recognize
this place or even a reference to an
earlier episode when the Hound tells
them that al is not there and I remember
that it's early kind of stuff counselor
but when he was burying their bodies
I remembered like oh oh if those guys
from that episode from whenever when he
still had Arya under his captivity and
they were hiding out there for a second
yeah the show really requires you to
remember everything that goes but before
he buries them the Hound asked the dari
in the dark I'm calling d4 now on down
ask D why does the god of light keep
bringing you back it was a question I
never asked myself either I never even
looked too much into that character but
when they were asking that question the
conversation that was following it
started making me think oh maybe this
guy is going to be built up to be
something even more important in later
parts of the show maybe he'll help aid
in the fight against the White Walkers
because that was a really cool scene
when the Hound is looking into the fire
and he starts to have visions of the
White Walkers approaching the the Nights
Watch wall because I like any show or
movie when a non-believer badass
character starts to believe in a higher
calling and I feel like the Hound is now
on this path of beat because he slowly
been a bad guy or something morphing
into a guy who could be for a higher
purpose something good and I feel like
with that extra layer of believing and
something spiritual can really aid in
his Redemption path and they cut back to
Sam where I'm glad I didn't just stop
with him cleaning up boo-boos going
through the books in Brent child-wife
I've done a girlfriend I forgot her name
never a name
Sam's girl Jilly Jilly I almost like
Gimli who is the dwarf and Lord
emergency and they come back to Sam and
he's looking through books he went into
the restricted mode now not restricted
mode
thing on YouTube he went into the
restricted wall area where he got a book
that to read upon the White Walkers and
he discovers where there could be
dragonglass located which makes that
scene all the more special you know
given some hope they got to season evoke
dragonglass is the only chance Johnstone
and the north have a chance of actually
defeating the White Walkers with but
then oh man when Sam is doing as usual
rounds of green up people's poop a hand
and an arm reaches out for and that's
covered in greyscale and it scares the
crap out of Sam and then you hear this
guy go cuz you see please could you show
the Pesci come yet the dragon queen
you're like oh crap that sure I'm so
excited cuz tours well my favorite
characters and truthfully I might have
missed it if the closed captions didn't
say Jorah with the following words of
his dialogue cuz I'm a little slow
sometimes it's so so sorry for that guy
in that moment man all this guy has
wanted is for Daenerys to be in love
with him that's always why
then he makes a promise that he's gonna
find a cure for the greyscale and I'm
glad he's still alive but man is he not
succeeding on getting this crap cure and
then the final scene Daenerys returns to
Dragonstone which i think is the first
time we're actually seeing Dragonstone I
might have been in the first season
I don't recall offhand you can leave a
comment and [ __ ] me out if you want or
you can just tell me yeah what was
really cool when she shows up the
production design of it all looks
fantastic you can see that doll that
talks about budget going up has really
been implemented here there's takes on a
flat it looks like a lettuce or flag
thanks for pointing that out by the
Lannister flag thing thank you and even
the layout for the throne kind of looks
like a setup to King's Landing thanks
for pointing out to by the way they're
all my observations I mean oh man and
then the show ends with Daenerys looking
at a table with his like 3d warlike
tables so they getting devised plans to
attack and says shall we begin
concluding the setup it's an exciting
ending because Circe's main concern is
Daenerys Jaime even tells Cersei she'll
be heading for dragon stuff Daenerys is
now at Dragonstone and once John gets a
letter from Sam he's probably going to
take some people and head to Dragonstone
as well to collect some dragon glass
which makes me think one
two things now keep in mind this is very
important nine times out of ten my
predictions like Game of Thrones are
wrong
I'm glad you tuned into this video one
prediction is when the three of them are
there John will convince them not to
fight with each other but work together
in order to take down the White Walkers
because right now John can't afford any
other enemies especially not Cersei his
main focus is has they've done the White
Walkers that is primary or to lessen
some problems John will work within
theirs along the way find out that
they're actually a family to fight
against Cersei and her forces help
Daenerys take over King's Landing John
Snow will commit some incest act with
Daenerys no one believes me on that like
I said my predictions are usually wrong
and it was cool too because a lot of
this episode while we got a more focus
on serving characters they still gave
hints that where other characters are at
you know Brienne of Tarth is still doing
her thing the north and she's even
training Podrick and Podrick is John
Humphrey I want you guys to know that
you know when you play that game which
character are you that's John Humphrey
and Daenerys returning back this whole
scene chillin it's one line the whole
episode and you do see Tyrion is there
and you it's like her team is like The
Breakfast Club that's how I have you
ever seen you got two eunuchs black
woman and it's like the most diverse
it's like the most random like you just
don't expect these group of people to be
in a group together one eunuch is a
psychological mastermind then you got
another eunuch is a soldier who's in
love with the black woman translator and
Tyrion to the little man I've lived
that's the PC word and the Greyjoy's are
there too I believe there's three
eunuchs plus the whole army good
anyway I really did enjoy the episode
I'm so excited for where this season is
going I I can't wait to tune in every
single Sunday I don't know if I'm going
to be one of those people who does a
review every week unless you really like
this video then maybe I'll carve out
some time what did you think people on
June snoo subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification bell follow me
at the Gregg owl on Instagram and
Twitter and as always make sure to check
out our exclusive person rewards over at
patreon.com slash the real rejects all
proceeds go to helping this channel stay
alive